before we begin I want to introduce our
two speakers so it's a pleasure to host
everyone here today and it's an honor to
host our two distinguished speakers
Jeremy Utley and Perry clay bond Perry
is a seasoned entrepreneur product
designer chief executive and co-founding
member of the D School faculty with over
20 years of experience he is the founder
of Atlas snowshoe company which grew out
of his master's thesis and which remains
the leader and snowshoe design and
Technology I think we all wish we had a
master's thesis that turned it into a
successful company he was also the head
of sales and marketing for Patagonia and
then went on to be named the CEO of the
Bag Company Timbuktu and I think for
anybody in the Bay Area or California
probably the world his success there is
pretty self evident because both are
such iconic California and especially
Bay Area brands even though Lee
Patagonia's is down the Central Coast
and that despite his years running
startups and corporations Perry's true
calling is teaching Jeremy meanwhile
never expected to be a designer he has a
background as a management consultant
focusing on economic development we'd
love to hear more about that and then in
2008 the d.school derailed him
completely and my understanding and I
think we'll learn about that a little
bit today is that's kind of the point of
the d.school to derail things and get
you to think differently his time there
showed him that how he worked was more
important than what he did and today he
is dedicated helping others along the
same path becoming a designer he
currently leads the D Schools work with
organizations as director of executive
education advising professionals and
organizations and how to embed the tools
of design thinking and cultivate an
innovative organizational culture so
with that it's my pleasure to introduce
both of them and to turn the
presentation over very jeremy yeah
thanks very much Bex you did a better
job of introducing us than we would have
done ourselves so Perry and I were
planning on using this slide to
introduce the topic today and introduce
one another but you've done a great job
so maybe we'll just jump right in period
and according at the outset what we
wanted to say is this
of how to innovate faster and better in
the time a co vid is a question on many
organizations minds is we're interacting
with leaders and certainly our students
as well both in the accelerator program
and also in the executive education
programs we run at the d.school
the question on everyone's mind is how
do we make sure that this crisis
accelerates our firms ability to
innovate and accelerates the kinds of
output that we are looking forward to
and what we'd say is most folks are
focused on output and output tends to be
the the focus of many conversations and
for us the key actually to innovating
faster and better in times of crisis is
to shift focus from output to input and
actually spend more time thinking about
what are the inputs that I need to be
seeking one of the disciplines I need to
be undertaking what are the practices
that I need to be engaging as a business
leader as an innovator as a catalyst
myself knowing that outputs are on
function of inputs if you think about
wanting to stimulate your imagination
imagination is triggered by unexpected
input and so when we think about
innovative output it's not agonistic of
some in but the question really is how
do I get deliberate and better at
intentionally seeking unexpected inputs
that are going to trigger my thinking
and so for us the question of how to
innovate faster and better in times of
kovat is really a question about
personal practice in seeking unexpected
sources of inspiration yeah as we as we
go forward a we wanted to introduce with
a quote from our favorite two-time Nobel
Prize winner - Pauling and at the core
sort of foundation of what we're going
to talk about in terms of practices we
asked you this whole question about
really the one of the themes you'll hear
us talk about the idea of generating
enough creative ideas if you're trying
to solve a problem so
was something that I know many of you
probably saw the talk with bond Sutton
and hug around Bob Sutton did a bunch of
research we're going to reveal but we
have some polling question really to get
a core concept out at the very beginning
this talk that's going to sort of allow
us to talk about some practices but sort
of establish with some data essentially
putting some numbers behind this book
from Linus Pauling how many ideas do you
need to have to come up with a
commercial success so let's look at the
whole results and see what what you all
come in in so we have you know the
middle of the curve here around 400
ideas to get to two to three commercial
successes so great so thanks for
participating let's let's show you the
results so this is some research yeah I
would say that that's pretty consistent
with what we see in organizations there
is a there's there's a when we think
about what the Linus Pauling quote to
get a good idea you need a lot of ideas
the question essentially is what's a lot
of ideas what's the definition of a lot
of ideas and we see folks routinely
underestimate the volume of material
that's required to ultimately deliver a
successful commercial alpha so here's
the research that Bob Sutton has
conducted in a longitudinal study of
innovative firms and what you see on the
right-hand side is two to three old
commercial successes and this is what we
call an exploration funnel but if you
work backwards through the funnel you
see ultimately to get to two or three
successes peri what needs to happen to
get there the twelve represents offers
that were sustained meaning we would
call this term incubated in the
vernacular here at Stanford but it means
that there was there was an effort to
put a real offer in front of customers
and sustain them as real offers for a
short period of time that's the 12
proceeding that the 226 is the number of
ideas that were actually prototyped made
in some way but we talk
a lot of Stanford about low-resolution
prototyping techniques but nonetheless
wrap your head around you know already
we have 226 things were built concepts
were put on and a some type of a
prototyping effort to get to the 2/3 and
then the first column is just a number
of ideas generated the number of
independent ideas maybe on a post-it or
a piece of paper on a whiteboard but
those are the what we'd say is what's
interesting is the the loss of ideas
that 95% of the ideas don't go on and
get prototype 95% of the programs don't
can incubate you don't think about that
that's a that's a core premise to what
we're about to discuss that Jeremy
mentioned that so many leaders and
organizations and teams underestimate
the amount of material they need to come
up with in the front of their what we
might call this the the innovation
funnel but it's here it's the
exploration follows to to come up with
new ideas that are going to be
successful are they generating enough
material and so so you can read further
if you want some nighttime reading this
will maybe put you to sleep so if you
it's great but it goes into a lot more
detail to this research and again credit
where credit is due this is some
research that Bob Sutton did but for us
when we think about this question of
innovating faster and better
it's really braiding in a sense I think
the first question for the innovator is
actually how are we filling the funnel
what is the source of inspiration to to
get that funnel as full as possible if
you know you're ultimately driving
towards commercially successful output
thinking that your first goal is
actually a question of volume is pretty
liberating and the the process does a
good job of down selecting or getting
rid of the material that shouldn't be in
the funnel but the the innovators job
and the
leaders job is actually what are the
practices where I can routinely be
filling the funnel as full as possible
and this for us the word that we would
use is inspiration how are you inspiring
or provoking fresh thinking about
solving new problems in the business and
for us as executives and as teachers to
interact with executives we would say
inspiration isn't a word that's really
on the corporate agenda there are in
folks think of inspiration they think of
those 1980s posters that hang in the
hallways that say things like teamwork
and have like a picture of a little boy
you know a t-ball practice or something
right there inspiration is this kind of
fuzzy thing but if you think about
creative individuals artists musicians
designers my wife's a fashion designer
right yeah by training and when she
wants to go to Paris
it's not for a vacation even though it's
great we love macarons that's all well
and good but the reason she wants to go
to Paris is because that's what
designers do to get inspired to provoke
their thinking when a design team goes
to New York they're seeking fresh
inspiration and we would say that folks
who are whose who see their
responsibility as creative output in
generating a high volume of output are
way more deliberate about sources of
inspiration than the typical kind of
leader or professional in a business
environment inspiration is not on the
radar at all I had a chance this past
fall to teach a class with a Grammy
award-winning hip hop artist named Alec
ray and lecrae and Brandon and Adam and
Seamus and I were interacting with a
bunch of students at Stanford and we
were prompting the students to be really
deliberate using a particular tool we
teach to be really deliberate about
seeking fresh inspiration to provoke
their thinking as they were solving a
challenge in our class and we had given
them the assignment and then I stepped
back and I said and one of the students
said you know I've never really thought
about inspiration before and I said look
great do you have any comments about
inspiration you know how do you think
about it as a musician and this is what
he said it really struck me
very simply said inspirations that
discipline and he went on to define that
discipline but for me that was kind of
an aha moment I don't hear professionals
talking about their discipline of
inspiration I hear creative
professionals I hear my wife I hear my
co-teachers who are you see their job as
delivering creative output being really
intentional about inspiration but it's
not something that most of us spend very
much attention attending to and so today
what we want to do is we want to share a
few practices and we use that word
practice deliberately because a lot of
times there's a we can think about I
need a new idea it's like I want to go
to the grocery store just gonna pick it
up on my way home just like a gallon of
milk or something like that right here
I'm just gonna grab a head of lettuce
and what we'd say is if you want to be
building a robust funnel of creative
output what you actually have to be
doing is thinking less like a like
somebody going to the grocery store and
more like a gardener are you cultivating
practices that are likely to yield a
creative output down stream and thinking
more like a gardener ideas aren't
something right just go by go by the
grocer or occasionally pick it up and
I'm on my way home and I'm fixing dinner
not at all
there outflow or an output of a
disciplined cultivation and careful
practice and so we want to explore today
are what are some of those practices
that we have gleaned from and observed
in creative professionals that we
believe there's a kernel of wisdom there
that professionals from far beyond
creative fields can apply to routinely
fill their funnels full and drive a
different kind of output down the funnel
so let's quickly Perry if you want to
cover the premises that we're going to
dive into them further
ok so we're going to go through five
practices and again the frame is
innovation and the time of kovin with
the crisis if your lives or anything
like ours I mean Jeremy are moving
classes online we're trying to have you
know previous things that we're going to
be trade shows and how are we going to
pull those off and we've got nothing but
sort of
um those types of things coming at us
and so given that if we sort of take as
as granted the Bob Sutton research the
biggest challenge is we need to generate
you know enough new ideas fresh ideas to
actually bet to get a breakthrough and
change something these are practices
that that are proven and will help you
do that okay
so we're going to talk about combining
perspectives a project to product
mindedness this practice of reversing
polarity which i think is a hoot and
then embrace embracing distractions and
finally commissioning a portfolio so
we'll go through each and tell in some
cases a few quick stories we invite as
packs send your questions so we'll
hopefully reserve a little bit of time
for that so the first one is combining
perspectives and there you found an
article from a school I didn't recognize
so it's on there yeah I you know I like
to I like to scour kind of the outer
reaches of the internet and I found this
website called Harvard Business Review I
hadn't heard of it before but it's very
interesting but you know in all
seriousness diverse teams are smarter
this is a great simple article that we'd
recommend and there's a lot of research
that indicates especially when you're
trying to do new work homogeneous teams
aren't the right answer and so when
you're thinking about if we want to be
filling the funnel with a lot of
material one of the simplest levers at
your disposal is being more deliberate
about incorporating unexpected
perspectives and we'd say that this is a
magical practice to incorporate
especially in the area of koban because
it's not it's easier than ever to
incorporate an unexpected perspective on
your team right your team's already
meeting on zoom' all you have to do is
think what a perspective that isn't
represented our team in our team or
someone whose input might provoke our
team's input in a fresh way what we'd
say is that the shelf life of diverse
perspectives is pretty short meaning it
doesn't take long for in
team to quickly be homogenized and
they're thinking and one of the simplest
tactics and practices you can employ as
a professional as an innovation leader
is being deliberate about incorporating
unexpected perspectives that's something
it's so easy to do right now and yet
it's so easy to overlook because we're
just booking meetings back to back to
back to back and we're executing and
what we'd say is that the leaders who
raise their heads up over the water line
or over the horizon it's fine and say
who could bring into this meeting that
will provoke fresh thinking or a fresh
input to our team it's a hugely
important question because new ideas are
a function of unexpected connections or
new connections and if you think about
and I'm sure everybody's seeing Network
models right but you had one person to a
network or to a collaboration there's
exponentially more connections that come
and a lot of times that's demonstrated
to show the difficulty of communicating
across network granted that's true
but what we'd say is it also represents
the innovation potential of adding an
additional perspective to an early stage
team the number of unexpected
connections that emerge and thus the
number of potential ideas so you can
pour into the top end of that funnel is
truly profound and Barry's got a really
really great example from his days at
Patagonia this shows just how meaningful
it is when you bring someone that you
wouldn't have ordinarily thought to
bring to a new endeavor so this is for
those of you know Patagonia is an
outdoor clothing and equipment company
I'm started in the 70s by Yvonne and
Melinda and aren't still owned by them
this brief company has a big
environmental mission I invite you to
take a look at it this is a if you
folded a catalogue open I was there in
the early 2000s and this was a product
we want to imagine folding the catalog
opening and spreading and flat that's
what you're looking at this is a product
we launched which is still quite quite
innovative
it's a wetsuit for those you don't know
wetsuit is something in colder water
surfers or divers or people awareness to
stay warm traditionally it's a onesie if
you will like a
the neoprene and it keeps you warm in
the water and in that time at Patagonia
we were very focused on a problem which
was we needed a stronger set of products
in the spring in the winter giving about
outdoor equipment we sell jackets
jackets cost more it's so our challenge
was you have to sell a lot of shorts to
make any money we need some some higher
priced products and we want to have a
presence in in the business of selling
things that are associated with spring
and summer so we thought about getting a
surfing line going and wanted to enter
the wetsuit market and wetsuits are you
know made of neoprene and and sourced in
certain places and we went off and
started down the path that we're gonna
make a better wetsuit with the mindset
oh I will say full of course I'm a
surfer so I invited myself along on this
junket but only reasonable to be a part
of the team yeah exactly we had that
mindset of it's gonna be a neo pretty
much I remember you know going on this
trip and with everybody but we did
something different and a process of
including these different perspectives
we brought along a person who as a
fabric designer who's involved with
fabric and sourcing fabrics
traditionally in clothing companies you
you have you know a designer design
something we do a set of drawings a
developer develops it finishes it and it
goes on through sales it's very much a
you know waterfall you goes from one
person to another person that's with met
a person we created if you will serve a
more agile structure with this this
diversity and broadening this fabric
person Tetsuo went on to a great career
and some other organizations but came
along on this trip and remember vividly
since he is not a surfer he just
understood fabrics they remember I'm
picking up a wetsuit and the first thing
he did was he smelled it smells kind of
funny and that was interesting he's a
very very skinny and the water was quite
cold so he put on the wetsuit and went
in the water and was cold so he walked
away with this new idea which was wow
this the fabrics wrong I could change
the fabric and ultimately what we have
here is the patio
wetsuit line which is in my
understanding he's still the only
wetsuit that uses wool so uses wool
because wool is antimicrobial
antibacterial isn't tend to smell it's
warmer by weight than neoprene the outer
part is is made of some different
materials it's natural rubber not not a
synthetic so it's quite quite different
and it actually allows the wetsuit to be
thinner and lighter which gives a better
experience for folks using it and to me
was a good example had we not combined
perspectives in that early stage and
gotten basically a whole bunch of new
fabric ideas at the very you know think
of our 4000 we all of a sudden had a
whole bunch of new ideas because of this
fellow
Ted Sudha adding them and ultimately
resulted in a in a very very innovative
product that has stood the test of time
to be still in the in a line since I was
there in early two-thousands that's an
incredible story very just of how much
of an impact someone who has no
experience with the particular space
you're considering right if you think
about inviting a collaborator probably
pretty low on the average person's list
would be someone who knows absolutely
nothing about surfing right what
business does that person have making a
wetsuit and yet it was that kind of
naive and totally a paradigm list
perspective right I'm sure all the other
surfers are are saying of course it's
bulky it's a wetsuit of course it stinks
it's a wetsuit and somebody with a
completely different perspective came in
and said well does it have to be bulky
does it have to stink they have some
fundamental questions that folks who are
used to the status quo never even
consider questioning what we have done
is we've considered we've asked our
alums and our programs to be thoughtful
about choosing collaborators who
represent a different perspective we put
a few different dimensions and granted
these may even be superficial dimensions
but the idea is being thoughtful about
selecting collaborators whose
perspectives are different from your own
knowing that it's those differences in
perspective that lead to the fresh
thinking that fills the file so that's
the first practice that we
recommend to gain inspiration the second
practice that we wanted to that we want
to mention is this idea of moving from a
product a project mindset to a product
mindset in many organizations whenever
new work is commissioned it's the the
blank project team everything is in
terms of project teams and what we want
what we have seen is there's an enormous
and untapped wealth of resources if
organizations will start thinking about
some internal capabilities that they
developed to service their organization
as potentially product isin bold
innovations a great example is Amazon
Amazon Web Services makes up a
non-trivial percentage of their market
cap and and investor you know
anticipations of growth of the company
and the interesting thing about AWS is
it started as an internal function it
wasn't designed originally as a product
that they would sell to developers
everywhere which now is driving their
business and driving all sorts of
meaningful growth for the company it
started as an internal hack the
developers made to make their own lives
easier and if you trace back the story
of AWS we're on insiders there but as
far as we understand it you can do a
little digging on this yourself one of
the things that precipitated the
development of AWS which is such a
game-changing disruptive technology was
internal memo Bezos sent to their
organization at one point maybe even
years before AWS is developed where he
basically said every single function
must be externalize Abul or you're fired
thank you very much essentially meaning
every line of code that was internal to
Amazon Bezos was pushing the
organization to make everything
externalize of all where folks outside
of the organization can hook into it and
for us there's an amazing question to
consider as a leader what projects
inside my organization are world-class
capabilities that we could actually sell
as a product to other customers and
further what products do we
we have there could be entire businesses
on their own if we thought differently
about that and again we've got a great
example from Perry's career a little bit
of a missed opportunity here you might
say we had this success story with the
with the wetsuit so we'll share this
story but good example of that mindset
not being present and missing an
opportunity yeah so this is one that's
you know it's just something this is the
straight talk we we think that telling
you the all the successes everything
goes up into the right this is one
that's just something I've reflected on
as a as a leader at Patagonia you know
we we had an amazing history for those
of you I'm sure everyone has had some
experience with a fleece jacket of some
time and which is a polyester product
and Patagonia was actually the inventor
of that with a cow small company Malden
Mills back in the 70s and the first
people to commercialize and build fleece
jackets that technology turn into many
many products in Patagonia's case but
one of them was a really successful line
of base layers undergarments fast
wicking t-shirts called capilene as
Alanis the name of the product and we
this was a great line of products we had
terrific people involved with designing
and doing it at night I as a I did not
have this project product line on the
side of item mindset when I got other
problems to do why would I why would I
worry about something we do world class
well why whatever why would I ever work
and almost and wish I had a mindset of
oh maybe you want to look at something
we're doing really well and see what
opportunities there are instead I took
the attitude oh I got problems with my
spring product line I need to help that
team innovate I need to go on that
search trip and in this period of time I
was there there was this this upstart
company that started doing all kinds of
things with the same fabrics and the
same technology called Under Armour and
people may have seen this they they sell
in general Sporting Goods that you all
kinds of products for team sports and I
remember vividly it's just a personal
sort of Patagonia does really well the
Capitoline line is strong they innovated
there they're doing terrific they're
doing
things with the product wise this is not
a story of a mistake that's the baby to
navigate through but I'd say as a
personal leader I never thought of
looking at the Under Armour example and
saying huh Wow we we do amazing things
with these same fabrics what if what if
we thought about other customers maybe
we don't want to sell it now for a
company two football teams which is I
think what I saw and just let it alone
it never looked at it again instead of
saying wow they're doing some really
interesting things for the fabrics
they're changing things and ultimately
Pentagon has done a lot of stuff with
the technology of capilene but as a
leader what a number thought of is
simply saying we have a capability we
have we have innovated we have built
this business with that capability could
I generate a funnel of ideas if I took a
product - and say our ability to do
think - this fabric is a product what
are the many many ways what is what are
my 4,000 ideas that that means something
I would say I have learned is a lesson
from this this circumstance we have a we
have a good friend who's recently
written a book where he talks about oak
trees only only grow to a certain height
but they drop acorns and if the only
focus of the business leader is to grow
the tree taller there's a problem and
his question is essentially how do you
strategically drop acorns which can
result in a forest and what we'd say is
the example of able us and many others
we've seen you know another example
comes to my mind we recently spoke with
the leader of a large hospitality
company and this leader told us the
story about how there's an internal team
that if there's underperforming retail
locations they have a team that comes in
and helps bump up their NPS score and
this leader mentioned how that internal
team is in high demand across the
organization with hundreds of locations
across the organization and many
locations are asking and we asked a
simple question have you sold that to
restaurants other hospitality comes to
other retailers and there's this moment
you can see the leader said we've
treated as a project we've never thought
about that as a new
yes and as long as it's only an
internally facing function that's fine
it'll make the existing business better
but there are many functions that could
be maybe even bigger businesses if you
shift that mindset a little bit so Perry
this is your favorite topic here this is
the third practice
so this one is reversing polarity so
it's a deceivingly simple concept and
one in practice I would say both Jeremy
I this is the one we routinely use
particularly when we're kicking off a
project it's basically a simple idea
that you brainstorm or generate ideas on
the opposite so a good example is
recently we we have a class a launch pad
it's an accelerator at Stanford one of
the seminal things that happens in that
class when it's in person which sadly
that classes are not in person currently
is a trade show and the founding teams
you know put together for the first time
their booth we have hundreds of people
and it's just this amazing event and we
were sort of seeing the calendar we sort
of still called the this event it's
called night launch and they we've left
it on the calendar we bought you know
and we're going go ahead and finally
make one of the moments jeremiad was
okay it's super challenging to see how
we're gonna pull this off and one of
these really helpful i review murders
jerry said what if it's no longer what
if it's just a class what if it's a
class what it's going to be what would
it be if it was just a class now and it
was just a class period what would it be
what are they in it it was the opposite
we've suddenly started brainstorming the
opposite rather than trying to figure
out how to solve this thing we said but
if it's not that oftentimes with
business leaders they will brainstorm
you know we're trying to hit the budget
for the year let's brainstorm on ways to
not hit the budget well we spend money
on if we're going to go over budget what
do you know and you you take those ideas
and you put them down in the funnel it
sounds goofy but it's yeah a lot of
times you can take a bad idea and it
generates start helps you generate those
four thousand ideas about what you could
do so tools for doing it
we would say it's all about put this in
the place in your head it's all about
getting to 4,000 ideas remember 4,000
ideas get you know 95% of them don't go
forward then another 95 percent so this
basically the practice and Bob Sutton's
talk to us about this is what when
you're generating ideas what's happening
in your head your head is just making a
series of connections and if you keep
asking the same question in your brain
you're driving some of the same
connections when you you reversed
polarity like this you just open up a
whole bunch of new connections and more
ideas start to come so if you don't
believe me try it in practice and we
certify these results you will generate
more ideas my name is Perry Clavin and I
certify this yeah
another example we're gonna give a bunch
of little micro examples of this broader
idea of reversing polarity but again the
point is to shake up your thinking and I
was struck over the weekend I was
reading something and saw about a ritual
the rock band a hair metal rock band
Aerosmith Steven Tyler mentioned to a to
an author at one point something that
the band done he did he said once a week
they have a ritual called a derrick
stuck meeting where every week we get
together and we say we each bring an
idea that we think is probably terrible
and we're embarrassed that we even have
this an idea and we present it and then
here's this Steven Tyler quote he said
nine times out of ten the idea is
actually terrible but one time out of it
and you get dude looks like a lady
right yeah if the goal is always best
material best material best material
sometimes that runs you right up against
a brick wall it is their space is there
a time where you say what if we're gonna
bring something that we know is
absolutely terrible just for the sake of
broadening our aperture and broadening
our thinking a little bit that's a great
practice of reversing polarity the other
ones are more academically established
this is one that we actually use in I
think most of our
based classes as an experience to put
the students through it's called a
pre-mortem honey route does some amazing
things with this in this class because
you're on the on the last webinar with
him here's a there's a link in here for
s ap did a great breakdown of a way to
do this with a set of scaffolds that we
thought was really well done so there's
a link here essentially it's a practice
to imagine we've got startup founders
that are you know going through getting
their first products in the market and
getting results one of the things we
find very very effective to use this
this this idea for reversing polarity is
we we just have a new a pre-mortem which
is essentially saying hey it's six
months from now and your startup is out
of business why do you want a business
what what caused it to fail and then you
take those aspects of failure you've
come up with and you think about well
how do I actually generate some ideas
that then won't happen on each one of
those and it ends up generating all
kinds of possibility and we think it's a
super powerful aspect to just simply go
through a short process for the team and
say hey if the jury seeing that we
haven't been successful why haven't we
been use that material to generate ideas
the basic another another simple tactic
is to say what's the worst possible
thing we could do what's the worst
version if we need to make a
presentation
what's the presentation we would never
want to give the point is a lot of times
thinking of what's my good idea is
really hard
what's my bad idea what do I definitely
not want to do sometimes it just I love
that notion of reversing polarity it
just he says the pressure enough that
ideas begin to flow again bill Burnett
who's a famed author of designing your
life is the executive director is the
product design program here Stanford
said if he says this to his Friday
design students never let your pin stop
moving because if your pin keeps moving
your brain keeps moving and a lot of
times when we face these roadblocks the
question isn't what's a really great
idea is how do I keep my pen moving and
reversing polarity is a really great way
to ensure that the pin remains moving
the next practice that we wanted to
mention is
the practice of embracing distractions
Questlove who's the drummer of the
hip-hop band the roots wrote a great
book recently called create creative
quests we'd recommend you check it out
but it's got lots of these kind of
artist inspired ideas for how do you get
ideas to start tumbling from your head
again one of the simplest and often
overlooked and easiest implements in the
midst of kovat is leave your computer
especially in the midst of all these
meetings and all you know Perry and I
were joking yesterday we're planning a
class for running executive programs
were planning summer programming all
sorts of stuff and we're saying well
where was that one and usually spatially
our ideas are represented right we've
got a space for our class plan and we
got a space for exec you have got a
place for the accelerator and on and on
and on you've got a place for online
classes but now everything is happening
through this little bitty portal and I
wonder why I can't keep anything
straight right and and we're in meeting
after meeting after meeting then we go
back to email then we go to the next
meeting commence it and are we surprised
that we're not getting fresh ideas we
shouldn't be surprised one of our mentor
David Kelly the founder of IDEO and the
founder of the diesel he once remarked
to us casually many of his best ideas
happened on the bike ride between
Stanford and ideas headquarters we don't
think that's accidental it's there's
this there's this notion of cognitive
dissonance meaning a lot of times are
our inhibitions are high we're saying we
need to focus and when we focus what do
we do we don't let in extraneous
information but how do we need when
we're trying to come up with new ideas
we actually need to let in extraneous
information
it's totally paradoxical but one of the
things we have to do is stop focusing a
little bit and taking a walk or going on
a bike ride is a really great way a mr.
ski who along with Danny Kahneman is the
father of behavioral psychology and
behavioral economics I love this quote
the secret of doing good work is always
to be a little underemployed you waste
years by not being able to waste hour
and especially in this time where
because we can't have face time in this
kovat era were also glued to our screens
and it's no wonder therefore why there's
no new ideas because we never have the
time to be a little bit disinhibited and
to allow unexpected inputs to come in
and one thing we'd say that's really
critical about this is you have to have
a frame in the world
so don't go on a walk and try to clear
your mind completely or go on a walk and
be empty-headed that's not going to
really help you
the question is we need got something
you're trying to work out is the is your
is the solution for working it out is it
pushing harder and harder and harder and
harder on the screen or do I having to
work it out I'm gonna go on a walk I'm
gonna work it out but I'm gonna read a
magazine we I talked with a wonderful
leader the other day said one of the
things he always says is he reads
outside of his discipline he subscribes
to a wallpaper magazine he's not into
design at all because he wants some
unexpected input to filter in and so
we'd say when you have a frame then
embrace distractions and one of the one
of the really interesting tactics here
is this idea of deliberately leaving
work unfinished we were really inspired
by Adam grant and his TED talk his book
originals is great but one of the things
that he references is a Russian
psychologist named Bluma Zeigarnik who
did a lot of research around once a task
is finished it leaves our minds but when
it's unfinished it stays on the back
burner so to speak is it still
processing it's still looking for an
answer it's so if we leave work
unfinished there's an opportunity our
minds are still trying to resolve it and
we'd say it's really important when you
think about trying to solve some
persistent problems trying to come up
with new ideas that you actually have a
problem in mind when you leave it's a
ways so to speak where your
most leaving the receptors open to
receive new information if all your
problems are solved when you leave work
for the day when you go on a walk your
receptor list with receptacle right but
if some of the work is unfinished all of
a sudden your receptors are open and
you're going through the world and this
idea comes and you go oh you know I was
sitting reading the other morning barri
and I had spent about half of our time
working through this deck and I was
sitting reading something unrelated and
all of a sudden the idea of gardening
versus grocery store came into my mind I
was trying to thinking what are we
getting that exactly and I hadn't solved
it I couldn't solve it sitting here and
I was reading the Bible I was reading
nothing related to innovation or
anything else it was like gardening and
the grocery store and I texted very
frantically we gotta have a slide right
but the point is it was that problem
wasn't resolved with me and Perry on a
zoom call batting it out what's the
right metaphor we left it unfinished and
the creative task yielded to our
willingness to embrace distractions
okay the last practice that we're going
to share before wrapping and going to
Q&A commissioning a portfolio so when we
looked at those those bar 4,000 ideas
226 prototypes 12 things incubated we
think of those when we use the team that
term portfolio we think of that as as
important it's a portfolio 4,000 I guess
it's a holding of Twitter 26 concepts it
support for 12 things being committed so
that's that's our term portfolio there's
there's amazing research about you know
problem solving in general scott clemmer
one of the founders of the d.school gone
on he's done loads of great research
there's an article will reference here
about parallel prototyping which is
another term for commissioning a
portfolio but the what he what he writes
a lot about and there's a lot of amazing
research about teams that are solving
problems particularly problems you don't
necessarily have a good sense of the
answer if you build simply but as Bob's
numbers show us if you build multiple
if you think of your output heads of
portfolio what what we need right now
for example in our teams at Stanford if
we're developing a new executive
education thing you know Catherine works
with us jeremy Perry we may all come
with you know post-it note schedules for
a couple versions of the program so we
arrive at a meeting with you know in
this case now pictures because they're
on the internet but we'll arrive each
with a couple versions of something and
we all of a sudden have this rich sort
of discussion about all these different
directions knowing what's the imminent
elimination rate you know we're coming
from they knew ninety five percent of
that stuff won't go forward so we're
understanding in advance we need to
generate a mountain of material if we
think of our output is how do we
constantly talk about how big is our
portfolio if we feel like we're not
getting somewhere and getting to new
solutions we diagnose it a lot of times
is we don't have a big enough portfolio
we're not building enough things to
actually pick through the other thing
interesting about Scott Clemmens
research it also talks it a little bit
about teams getting through projects
with a lot of uncertainty if they're
doing parallel prototyping in other
words building portfolios they tend to
function better because it was less
argument because there's a lot of
solutions on the table it's not my
solution I'm trying to push forward I
already have we have many many things
we're looking at and we're sort of
picking our way through this uncertain
problem by by seeing some results what
we love is this idea of the portfolio
being your output that it's not if you
think about the one or two ideas the one
or two commercial successes is the
output
it's the that's the wrong way to think
about it in the beginning the the myriad
of potential directions is actually the
meaningful output if you know that that
very a very low percentage of the total
some of the things you do are going to
succeed what does a smart person do they
do a lot of things so if you want to
succeed do more things we've got some
very close collaborators at a you know
multinational corporation who
they run an internal incubator and
they've specified a failure goal and the
the leaders incubator actually punished
if they don't reach the failure goal why
because they know that if they aren't
failing enough they're probably being
too safe they're probably exploring too
narrowly and so the point is just having
a totally different mindset when our
goal is exploring if we aren't failing a
significant portion of the time we're
probably being safe and that's a
dangerous place for us to be when we say
our goal is to do something dude right
so we will so we'll wrap here I think
we'll say our last comments on each each
of these five practices combining
perspectives about deliberately inviting
folks outside of the scope of your team
into your team setting to provoke fresh
perspectives moving from a project to a
product mindset is considering
commercializing world-class capabilities
in order to launch new businesses and
reversing polarity is that idea of
literally doubling Maine potentially
doubling the connections in your head by
just asking the opposite question
embracing distraction is about
triggering new connections by seeking
fresh input and remember make sure that
your brain is actually open to new input
by leaving some questions unresolved or
some problems unsolved and finally
commissioning a portfolio this idea that
at the very beginning think of the if
you will that bar the output being the
portfolio not the individual success and
actually allowing teams to see that that
diversity of those concepts and navigate
through using the portfolio as we move
into a Q&A time we've got about 12
minutes left here for Q&A we thought we
just leave this Kevin Kelly quote he
recently turned 68 and he posted a list
of 68 truths that he wanted to impart to
the world on his 60th birthday we
this this is all about preserving the
the gardening mentality preserving the
space to create knowing that as we
attend to the input and as we develop
and cultivate those practices of
inspiration seeking that's what allows
innovation to flow faster more routinely
and even better so with that I think
we'll turn it back over to pax who will
introduce some of the first questions
great Thank You Perry and Jeremy that
was a fantastic question I saw this
that's echoed through some of the
comments over a number which was
starting to dive in but I want to make
sure you cover this because it's just so
practical and it's it's many of you
asked this is in some way shape or form
can you discuss how this approach
approached fits into lean organizations
that have very real budget constraints
so I would say I don't I don't know I
mean then there's a few bits that aren't
but most companies now are facing an
enormous budget constraints and what
what I'd say about these things is I
often times when we give a talk like
this
the assumption is wow I've got a
schedule a time for this I've got it
I've got to make space for this on
people's schedules it's going to cost
something for me to take on any one of
these practices and what we would say is
you know something like brainstorming
the opposite something like getting a
different perspective on a problem is as
simple as you know calling a friend and
saying hey I'm working on this project
we're doing these things what are your
thoughts you have a different take on
this it doesn't mean you've got to get
ready and change a lot of things that
might incur costs we would say starting
these practices as low resolution as you
can is 8h horrific strategy initially
and also these things combined I mean
the reason we did multiple tools is as a
as a leader or a member of a team
somebody worked really well for you in
your
and your business and some might not be
that easy to to to bring in but we say
all of them have a little of the idea of
embracing distractions taking along a
stack of post-it notes the next time you
take a break and and take a short walk
and and let the ideas come but you build
that into your practice meaning I do
that as a leader as a somebody on a team
trying to solve a problem I'm making
space using one of these techniques
we're hoping that's that fad construed
and at least in your mind is something
that's going to take a lot of effort a
lot of budgeting a lot of scheduling
running something like a pre-mortem with
a team is something I would take on as a
leader once you've established
there's something about brainstorming
the opposite it's that's actually really
working for myself I'd like to introduce
it to a team then there's a practice
that you could take you know 20 minutes
of a team's time and do something to
help generate some ideas I have a
there's another question that I thought
was pretty cool I'm just looking at them
as they're coming in how do we do idea
generation asynchronously as well as
synchronously what's better
I guess you're creating a portfolio it's
kind of a yeah I like the stream of
consciousness there I would say they're
both really useful I would say a
synchronous meeting is very important if
it's built on the shoulders of a
synchronous consideration so a lot of
times when folks are brainstorming or
trying to generate ideas together which
is by the way one of 1,000 ways of
coming up with ideas right in this
notion of inspiration more broadly that
we've been undertaking today and the
basis of the new assignee course on
inspiration is exploring the other 999
ways but right brainstorming is
important that only works if people have
been thoughtful coming into the meeting
if there's been no thoughtfulness coming
into the meeting there's no surprise
that the result is frivolous or
unrealistic right Justin Berg has done
some really interesting research that we
reference in that course and we can send
along here as Paxson is mentioning as
well
Justin Bernie's done some really
interesting research on there's always a
trade-off between novelty and usefulness
and his research indicates that one of
them
important indicators of long-term
success is what he calls the primal mark
or to use kind of an artist kind of
metaphor the first brushstroke is really
important in determining the ultimate
implements ability of a solution meaning
if the first brushstroke is entirely
frivolous it's really difficult to get
that idea into useful territory if on
the other hand the the the first
brushstroke is very very pragmatic and
reasonable it's very hard to move it
into new territory and so what we'd
suggest is if you're going to have a
synchronous meeting allowing folks the
time individually asynchronously
especially respecting the spectrum from
extraversion to introversion respecting
where folks are in that huge kind of
spectrum giving folks time to consider
what is the unique contribution they're
going to bring to the meeting is really
important and having that thoughtfulness
is really important and then being able
to facilitate that meeting to not only
express and to showcase the diversity of
perspectives and ideas but also to to
start to lather up so to speak or to
from the basis of those ideas from the
foundation of those ideas to build to a
place where none of the folks in the
room and imagined prior to entering the
room that's another art in and of itself
so there's real value to the
asynchronous stuff and then there's real
merit to the synchronous as well and for
us it's not any either/or it's of both
end and being deliberate about when to
do what is the important thing so
there's a there's a couple questions
there there's so heartfelt this one in
many ways I've seen in a lot of the
comments and I think a chart how do you
do all this under big pressure you know
just was talking this morning before
this with a really good friend that's
got a company American giant and he was
lamenting because I'm still clothing and
I love all that stuff anyway so the
company but he was probably literally
about this is I know I need to solve
some things and yet I have no time in my
day none none whatsoever and I'd say
that the thing to think about is maybe
disservice by showing hey there's all
these tools there's all these things you
can be doing things ing many many things
it sounds super interesting and you car
but we appreciate in this time you've
all carved out the time to be here and
we do believe these are needed something
as simple as combine perspectives
I know Jeremy and I have found this time
in particular during coven we're finding
peers are available meaning people are
willing to help and I know we've called
friends with our classes that are
suddenly moving online and we're having
to change everything
we've definitely had these short quick
conversations to gain some different
perspective and just adjust our thinking
so we can get some fresh ideas but that
would be an example of something that's
a 10-minute phone call that's that's
talking to somebody that's out of
Stanford not teaching they're working in
a different environment but we wanted a
some some creative new ideas so we'd say
be selfish about saying if I only have
minutes if I'm not busy let's use
something like that this I can fit a
quick phone call in and call in a favor
but trying to right-size them to the
circumstances right now
and not taking the attitude of how do I
stop and reconfigure and and begin to
bring all these things in in a way
that's higher resolution or there's any
burden I think all of these tools could
be used in a very quick and simple way
that allows you to handle all the
burdens you have and all that stress but
our hope is you begin to see them
actually increase your performance in
solving the problems that are so
pressing alright speaking of pressing
there's three minutes left and I'm dying
to answer one more by the way there's a
ton of questions it's awesome I feel
like we like right on this but here's
here's another question which is really
great how do you test your ideas in
times of coated what are some examples
of measures of success so this is such a
great question I love it
Kerry and I just did a session actually
last week with the bio design fellows
and the bio design team you know it's a
bunch of undergrads and doctors and
practitioners and fellows making
biomedical engineering devices and they
are when they think about prototyping
they're always thinking about like I
mean
we went to their presentations through
thinking about microns of depth into an
ear canal for example it's not point
zero zero zero zero nine it's point zero
zero zero zero eight right that's how
they think about prototyping and to me
when you think about testing or
prototyping they need to test in terms
of physical that way it can be
constraining this koban environment can
certainly be constraining right and it
is that's a reality but when you think
that there's multiple streams of
prototyping this is actually critically
important one important stream of
prototyping is the product and we make
it is it technologically possible that's
very important another one is kind of
business viability can we make money
making it and there's all sorts of
prototypes you can deploy there another
type of prototype and one that's
actually really well suited to this
kovat environment is is a desirability
should we make it do people want it and
that it what we would call that
promotional prototyping the way to
answer that question is not ask people
if they want something right what your
goal what your goal should be to create
high credibility data and it's a route
like surveys are generally very low
credibility why because you're paying
people to answer your questions and
they're not paying you it costs someone
nothing to tell you to do that your
ideas great go do a bunch of work right
wow that sounds amazing spend a hundred
thousand dollars building that and send
me an email but I'll ignore and put my
spam right that's not what you want so
promotional prototyping over here right
they specified kind of three lanes
promotional prototyping we Tate's making
offers where someone has to make an
actual decision which gives you what we
would call proprietary and much higher
credibility data for example if you know
that your target user is this kind of a
person mothers you know with with
multiple kids who are trying to do home
schooling in kovat great you have your
target user and you think their problem
is blank great use MailChimp or
something set up an a/b test with all
your testing is a subject line of an
email right and all your tracking is
open rates right you'll be shocked that
the value
proposition that you think is
mind-blowing it's an open rate of like
1% right but if you start thinking about
okay well what are other ways I could
express the value I'm creating here I'm
gonna put it in a different subject line
on I'm gonna compare it to the base case
right there's really and then you put
the same copy in both emails that you
put a link in both emails any track
click-through rates and then if you have
different instances of your website you
can track dwell time and sign up for
more information or PDF downloads but my
point there is someone's not telling you
what they will do they're showing you
what they do do and you want a high
credibility data and its really simple
through simple Prout promotional
prototyping techniques to be creating
data that you can put a lot more
confidence end it's just as important
data as the you know to the micron level
of accuracy for the ear canal both are
critical Colvin is particularly
well-suited to promotional prototyping
and there's really great ways to do that
hopefully that's helpful
I'm going to hand it over to Thomas
Thank You Perry and Jeremy that was
really wonderful I appreciate it I hope
everyone took something valuable away
something they can implement right now
and I want to thank everyone who
participated today this has I think was
the best Q&A that I've ever seen and and
so will will be compiling these
questions ways that we can address them
and again a recording will be sent out
and I want to especially thank Parian
for the wonderful presentation and ideas
during this challenging time thank you
everybody thank you
you